thérèse nous yen se souvient du 30 avril
comme si c'était hier il y avait des
bombardements
juste en arrière de notre maison
d'où le matin elle apprend qu'un dernier
navire s'apprête à quitter ses gonds
elle et son mari décide de fuir avec
leurs huit enfants le plus jeune à trois
ans les petits n'ont que leur pyjama sur
le dos brou marie c'est un scooter
et puis ma soeur une moto souvenez vous
l'été
rendez vous au port cela c'est quelque
chose qui lui donne la chair de poule
aujourd'hui parce que on s'est éparpillé
mais on savait pas que le point de
rendez-vous c'était le chaos total
c'était des milliers de milliers de
personnes qui paniqué comme nous fait
que on s'est retrouvés par miracle à ce
qu'elle aurait pu entendre quelques uns
arrivée au port les nouilles n réalise
avec effroi que le dernier bateau
transportant des réfugiés est déjà au
large
autre miracle il trouve une chaloupe qui
leur permet de rejoindre le navire
surchargé
conçu pour 500 passagers ils en
accueillent 4007 flotte sur l'autre se
passe tu vas vivre non pendant les gens
cliquent et le souvenir qui m'a marqué
le plus c'est quelqu'un qui se tiraient
une balle un homme qui se tiraient une
balle à côté de moi j'avais j'avais tout
ça sur moi mais ma mère elle a dit que
je me suis évanoui
au troisième jour en mer le navire se
met à prendre l'eau malgré tout thérèse
ne regrette pas un instant sa décision
de fuir les bombardements
elle ne pense qu'a trouver de l'eau pour
les enfants quand on la femme saine on
peut on peut résister mais quand on a
soif c'est dangereux
je ne sais pas pourquoi ce tournage je
mets pas pas du tout j'ai confiance
c'est pour ça je dis je l'appelle mon
héros parce qu'elle était tellement fort
et c'est oublié elle est toujours là
dernière la dernière à monter sur lol le
bateau la dernière à quitter le bateau
ces rescapés sont finalement sauvés par
un cargo danois qui les emmène en cause
après six semaines dans un camp de
réfugiés et nguyen arrive à montréal et
les trois thèmes de mon blog était le
succès le bonheur et la réussite
quarante ans plus tard zunie est devenu
entrepreneur
après avoir été ingénieur à radio canada
mon père avait trois jobs au moins ma
mère manufactures aient travaillé dans
un hôtel mon père était au théâtre
st-denis a déchiré les billets mais ça
c'est après une grosse journée où il
était debout à repenser alors il
travaillait très dur
alors quand tu vas à l'école et que tu
reviens pas que tu votes des parents
travailler dur que dormir pas beaucoup
d'heures à tout les soirs tu peux pas tu
peux pas ne pas réussir à l'école du
petit peu plein de projets la seule
chose que je pouvais leur donner comme
fierté c'est que leur montrer regarder
mon bulletin
cette puissante volonté de réussir les
vietnamiens l'ont transmise à la
nouvelle génération née au québec
pour moi c'est vraiment inspirant que si
l'on fait d'aller d'une vie très
confortable avec presque tout un pays
étranger où il avait presque rien
thérèse et vincent ont gagné leur pari
les enfants qui ont fui la guerre en
pyjama au tour aujourd'hui au moins un
diplôme universitaire est un bon emploi
trois étapes puis on met ça dans youtube
julie est des immigrantes à se lancer en
affaires
ils portent en eux oui il y en a qui
portent des souffrances il y en a
d'autres et porte des expériences de la
culture c'est tellement riches qu'ils
arrivent ici comme moi et ma famille et
entre 115 et recommencer une nouvelle
vie
je vois on a eu beaucoup d'opportunités
potentiel mais de moins en moins de
réfugiés arrivent au canada
à l'époque nous avions accueilli 130
milles vietnamiens 60 mail dans une
seule année depuis le début de la guerre
en syrie il y a quatre ans seulement
1166 réfugiés syriens sont arrivés au
canada
thérèse ne comprends pas pourquoi on
n'ouvre pas grand nos bras aux rescapés
de la mer venant d'afrique et du moyen
orient
on doit les accueillir mais je pense
c'est sain c'est compliqué aussi
c'est compliqué les politiques
je comprends pas pourquoi c'est
compliqué mais dans mes pommes et c'est
compliqué maintenant mais par avance les
beautés passa presque marcy à errer sur
les bateaux
depuis 15 mois près de 5000 personnes
sont mortes en méditerranée en tentant
de rejoindre l'europe c'est terrible
j'ai je pense à tous les jours qu est ce
que je peux faire pour essayer d'arrêter
un ces sortes de choses
c'est quoi cette part ne pas aider et tu
vois quelqu'un qui dans une situation où
tu dois aider
tu peux pas risquer de perdre des vies
humaines comme cela si j'ai les moyens
je vais recevoir délai les gens
surtout les enfants les enfants répéter
enfin